this is 100 million buys huh it wasn't  that hard to find you Toretto was an ID  last week a team of highly coordinated  drivers took down an entire military  convoy  you're gonna help me catch the team  responsible now why is that been chasing  this crew across 12 countries this was  taken a week ago  it's impossible I need your help Dom I  need your team got the best crew in the  world standing right in funny give them  a reason to stay  I'm targets Owen Shaw for years they've  been running jobs in Europe but a most  recent job graduated them to a whole new  level you get as close to Letty and  we'll give you shot and you give us full  pardons all the way around not dealing  with cops drug dealers I've never seen  this before  it makes you predictable reach out and  break you whenever I want  you believe in ghosts maybe the Letty we  once knew is gone you don't turn back  even when they do  we talk a vehicular warfare  this is not what we do